this video was made possible by
Squarespace
build your custom website for 10% off by
going to Squarespace calm / Wendover
China is a country both blessed and
cursed by geography on one hand it's
land has allowed for the country to grow
to almost 1.4 billion people but on the
other hand it really doesn't have great
geographical protection the beginning of
what most people call Chinese history
often starts with the Yellow River
civilization and there's a good reason
why this settlement grew into the most
populous country in the world the flood
plain of the Yellow River is some of the
best agricultural land in the world in
fact the entirety of eastern China is
perfectly suited for agriculture this
was and still is crucial to the
country's success what's more this area
is just warm and wet enough that farmers
can do what is known as double cropping
once the main crop of rice is cultivated
in June and July another slightly less
productive crop can be planted for
October cultivation this increases rice
output by about 25 percent which means
China can make more food using the same
amount of land Europe mostly relies on
wheat to feed its population which only
outputs 4 million calories of food per
acre of farmland rice on the other hand
grows 11 million calories worth per acre
it's easy to see why there are so many
people in China but China does have its
geographical challenges to the South a
borders three countries Vietnam Laos and
Myanmar the borders between these three
countries in China seem almost
arbitrarily set because they sort of
were Viet Nam's was set after the
sino-french war Laos is was set
following its involvement in the Vietnam
War and Myanmar's was set following a
small war with China in the 60s none was
naturally set by the environment all
were chosen arbitrarily by humans at war
these countries are not insignificant
combined they have nearly 1 million
active military personnel while China
the much larger country has just over 2
million
significant conflict with any of these
countries would not be a one-sided war
while China would have the technological
vonage any of these three countries
would have a significant home-field
advantage Vietnam Laos and Myanmar are
all jungle countries one of the most
difficult environments for warfare this
was part of the reason why the Vietnam
War lasted so long it's just so hard to
move troops in the jungle so everything
slows down without any geographical
protection of its borders it would be
significantly easier for Vietnam Laos or
Myanmar to invade China than the reverse
but China does have an advantage
elsewhere China and India just aren't
good friends they have border disputes
military conflicts political differences
so it's just hard for them to get along
and that's why Tibet is so important
Tibet was historically its own empire it
was only in the last 300 years that
China took it over Tibetan people are
ethnically different than the Han
Chinese inhabiting China's East it just
doesn't make sense for Tibet to be part
of China except militarily only 0.2
percent of China's population lives in
Tibet which accounts for nearly 13
percent of the country's area more
people live in the inner four districts
of Beijing than the entirety of Tibet
it's just incredibly desolate but it
serves a purpose if China didn't rule
Tibet then India would maybe not
formally but there's little chance that
an independent Tibet would not be
economically and culturally dominated by
either India or China it just doesn't
have enough power economically or
militarily to resist but in China's view
it could not and cannot allow for an
Indian Tibet Indian rule of Tibet would
mean that there would be no geographical
protection between the populated area of
China and India because Tibet is that
geographical protection not only does
Tibet extend China's border to the
Himalayas it's also an unpopulated area
without the transportation
infrastructure needed for an invading
India to advance a large number of
troops towards eastern China but that
also means that there's not the
transportation infrastructure necessary
for China to advance towards India but
China is trying to change that they
recently opened the world's highest
railroad to Tibet there
building highways constantly and they
also opened a large Airport in yang Qi
just miles away from the porter in the
near-term
the goal of these projects is to further
integrate Tibet into China the
government has all but failed at winning
over the native Tibetan population but
they can change who lives in Tibet
hundreds of thousands of Han Chinese
have moved into Tibet and many more
visit each year the government knows
that the bets usefulness is diminished
if when a foreign military shows up the
population thinks that means liberation
rather than invasion but there's another
reason China needs to bet water the
whole eastern zone of agricultural
productivity exists because of all the
water from Tibet the yellow and Yangtze
rivers China's two longest rivers both
get their water from Tibet and foreign
control of the water supply of the
country would in the government's mind
strike a catastrophic blow to the
country's food security if there were
hypothetically a significant mountain
range separating Tibet from eastern
China there's a good chance it would
still be independent the water would
still come from China and the mountains
would act as the geographical protection
that China desires but to the north is
another one of China's assets Mongolia
it's an enormous sparsely populated
friendly country with the Gobi Desert
and other desolate terrain there's just
a little chance that any modern
land-based army couldn't make it across
with any efficiency the supply lines
would be enormous Li long and by the
time they got to the Chinese border
there would have been ample warning but
then again who would want to invade
Mongolia's only other neighbor is Russia
which is a friendly ally of China both
militarily and economically China need
not worry about its northern border
until relations with Russia sour but
that leaves the eastern border now you
would think that this would be China's
safest border the ocean but you have to
consider that powerful States lead just
off China's Shores most powerful one
being the u.s. the United States has a
significant Pacific military presence
with bases in South Korea Japan and Guam
it's also a close ally with Taiwan
Indonesia Singapore and Malaysia meaning
that if a serious dispute with China
the US would have no problem blockading
China and cutting off its maritime
access and of course China knows this
that's why China has spent so much time
energy and political capital to
establish sovereignty in the South China
Sea by building military bases and
artificial islands it knows that it
needs these islands so it has
sovereignty over the area so it can
reach the Pacific in case of war but
ironically its actions in the area are
souring its relations with the very
nations that china needs on its side the
Philippines for example doesn't have a
bulletproof relationship with the US
while the two countries are allies
Philippine leadership has attempted to
distance themselves from the u.s. if
China hadn't ruined its relationship
with the Philippines over the South
China Sea dispute it could have won them
to their side which would allow China
crucial access to the Pacific if the
u.s. attempted and naval blockade
China's entire economy relies on exports
so restrictions to access to the oceans
would lead to economic ruin with its
enormous population China also relies on
the importation of food most of which
comes on ships without jobs or food
there's a good chance the population
would rise up against the government and
end the current regime China didn't want
to be a global power spreading its
influence to every continent until
recently it wanted to be the dominant
power in its region Asia but
historically it kept its affairs within
the region it never colonized outside of
Asia and for much of history it didn't
have a significant Navy to project its
power around the world but that has
changed because China got so big
China is now of a size where it cannot
support its population with its size
alone self-sufficiency and food
production was a major aspect of China's
domestic policy for decades but the
country has found a way to move past it
as its economy has grown Africa has
emerged almost as China's China it
supplies the country that supplies the
world China has pumped enormous amounts
of money into the continent in what some
describe as a form of neocolonialism
Chinese state backed corporate
Asians have bought huge amounts of land
in Africa to mine minerals drill for oil
and grow food China now imports more
food and oil than in exports while that
is a sign of the development of its
economy it also means that it is now
reliant on foreign powers which is a
vulnerable position for a country that
is often at odds with some of those
foreign powers China doesn't have bad
geography it is some of the best in the
world which has allowed for it to grow
into the largest country in the world
but as it grows into a more and more
powerful and developed country it needs
to be cognizant of its vulnerabilities
if the current regime wishes to continue
it's clear that because of its geography
the country is in a more precarious
position than some may think if there
were ever a reason to go to war with
China the country is surrounded to the
south and east by countries that would
likely side with NATO powers to the west
and north China is surrounded by
countries and regions without the
infrastructure to support China in a war
China is a nuclear power which means
formal war with other superpowers is
unlikely but if it ever were to happen
it's hard to deny that its major
disadvantage is its geography I just
went through the process of building the
new website for my other channel half as
interesting all in it took me about an
hour to make this simple website and the
hosting fees are very reasonable for
whatever you do whether it's a YouTube
channel a business or anything else
having a professional web presence is
incredibly important because that's how
people find you
Squarespace makes this easy with their
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers powerful website
builder and 24/7 award-winning customer
service no matter what you do build your
web presence for 10% off with
Squarespace by going to Squarespace comm
slash Wendover Squarespace makes this
show possible so please at least go
check them out over at squarespace.com
slash Wendover thanks for watching and
I'll see you in two weeks for another
Wendover productions video
[Music]